[Music]
welcome back to off the record where we
talk about whatever
we want baby and today we have bobby
dean
are you good thank you i feel like it's
been like
two years or three years probably longer
it's been a minute yeah my years are all
messed up okay when was the last time
you were on jk news
2015
there you go like 15 16. yeah
[Music]
it's been a yeah minute what you've been
up to
you know just living life trying to
create more um working on some projects
and stuff like that did you catch cover
19. i did not
i did not get your ice cream you did
we all did everybody everybody yep so
you're safe
uh no i mean i i didn't get tested so i
don't know
oh [ __ ] you haven't been tested she's
got gonorrhea though
we got tested yesterday no we did we got
that we've done the
test here but we have test kits we did a
test before because we went out for
christmas time yeah and we got a test
then it was negative
but in between i don't know so that's
how you know we're saying we just tested
yesterday
but we have these boxes here and you can
test
uh within 15 minutes they give you the
results not a brand deal but you should
sponsor us
for real because we use this like every
week yeah
it's the same [ __ ] it's the same [ __ ]
that you get when you go to those urgent
cares
the same rapid test it's the same thing
i even get it
moving on to bobby
[Laughter]
not a brand deal not a brand deal but
why did you um use those tests yesterday
oh well because uh we actually did jk
party
and we haven't done that in a long time
for you people
yep but it's only on patreon because you
know youtube's trying to screw with us
so
everyone watching this is on youtube yes
we are doing jk party games
mafia stuff like that and uh david
was afraid to come because he was like
i'm not getting coveted twice because
last time
i hang out i hung out with you guys i
got the kovitz oh yes [ __ ]
yeah so we're like all right well we're
all gonna test right in front of you and
you see the results
and then it'll be okay we were all
negatory
yeah wait but like being that you guys
had it already was it as bad as people
you know describe it or it's the
pussiest thing i've ever gone through
i think everyone it's a different
experience everyone has a different
experience and then like you know later
on they found out there's so many
different strains so it really depends
on what strain you get and also it
affects
people differently too yeah yeah so for
me since i have asthma i was pretty much
scared throughout the whole year because
it's a attached respiratory system yes
and then so like the minute i got i was
like oh [ __ ] i'm gonna be so [ __ ] so i
got my [ __ ] inhaler i'm [ __ ] like
sleeping with it
and then like two days went by and i'm
like the [ __ ]
you didn't have the cops i'm like dude
i've had flues and colds
that were worse way worse than this [ __ ]
i don't need this [ __ ]
and then but then you also hear people
that like
don't smell or taste for nine months or
something did you have that problem you
could taste it the taste and smell the
whole time
and then there's people that have like
like shaking chills for two weeks
what about your body did you have like
the body age i had the body
you had the body for me that was the
worst part but other than that it wasn't
that bad i didn't lose my strength ever
the taste and smell thing was a trip for
sure i couldn't even smell chlorine
whoa whoa could you get a boner i had
boners for sure
i didn't really expect your boners no i
didn't have a bone no
no could i usually have morning wood and
then i didn't have morning wood for like
four or five days i had a boner but it
was numb was it
my whole body got numb you know what i
don't think i had a boner you did it
right i don't think i did
are you a morning what kind of guy yeah
for sure yeah see that's a brag
who isn't a morning wood kind of guy
when you're stressed out it's difficult
that's true you probably don't get
morning when you're stressed out
oh maybe you're stressed out because you
have covet
because my mom kept [ __ ] calling me
you're gonna die i was gonna die and i
didn't pick up the phone one time and
like didn't call back like an hour and
she thought i died
oh my gosh she's worried did you tell
did you tell her that you had kovit
not what did she watch the youtube
uh yeah she found we texted the family
that we had code yeah
that's crazy like did you like [ __ ]
with her oh yeah i love [ __ ] my mom
so my mom watches the vlogs
afterwards so she found out that i had
covet i think like two or three weeks
later you didn't call your mom and tell
her no
oh my god you got covered i'm like oh
i'm in the hospital but what am i gonna
do
and then i like [ __ ] went there and
then a month afterward i told her i
caught it again she's like again i'm
like i know it's so crazy
i actually [ __ ] with me because uh
when um
bart was dishing out the wuhan wagyu um
we all got it at his house but i waited
five though
eight days i waited like over a week to
get tested because i
you know you usually you can't do it
like immediately and then so
i did both and it came out negative but
then the way and i didn't have any
symptoms but the way i found out is i
was eating
and then i couldn't taste it yeah i was
like oh [ __ ]
that's a signature symptom yeah and then
for two days i couldn't taste or smell
anything so i was like yeah this is
probably it and i took a home kit
and it's like got it oh so the home kit
told you but what was the other test
that you were doing
i went to the doctors i went to urgent
care oh yeah but this was like
four or five days after i got tested so
it was like
hella weird like dormant or whatever
yeah and i didn't feel i didn't get
anything
like i just couldn't smell and taste and
then my body was kind of numb
and that was it dude props to cover that
[ __ ] is contagious as [ __ ] for sure
yeah i gotta give props well cause i was
hating on coving a little bit but then i
gotta get i gotta give a little bit of
props
a little bit how do you how does it feel
to be in a room full of day walkers
we've been turned yeah i mean it is what
it is i mean
at least with you guys i know what's up
you guys have you know
had it experienced it yeah i'm probably
engaging with people on a
daily basis who i don't even know so
you know oh yeah you're doing your
podcast now right with
cast members because before we were
doing it like um i went on our podcast
we did it just
we live streamed yes yeah and i saw
recently
you have like people in your uh studio
well those are i was gonna say well no
those are throwbacks those are
throwbacks
yeah just because see like you guys you
guys have a nice space where people can
be spaced out
our studio is like super tiny and like
we have a little couch and everything so
i don't want to make people
uncomfortable but hopefully i'm trying
to
find a space where we'll be able to do
something maybe similar to this
what's your podcast about everything
girl we talk about everything
yeah so sometimes i'll put myself on
blast well
like i said earlier dating sucks so
we'll talk a lot about my dating life
and how it's trash
and what sucks about dating what do you
mean what time dude just staying dating
i showed her like that good day no one
wants a day no one's a date
dating no not even just because i just
want to hook up yeah
but they'll like waste your time and
make it seem like they want a date like
i went on an amazing date the other
like okay well maybe a few days ago
whatever greatest [ __ ] day ever
we're talking for hours everything's
cool and then
cricket cricket that's it yeah that's it
what that's it
i was like we talked like a day or two
after that and then that's it
that's it i was like okay thanks for the
free meal thanks for watching
you didn't even get dig after that no i
didn't get
so like you but you had an awesome
conversation hey but it was a nice meal
what yeah i'm like i could have done
that with my girlfriend that's so weird
did you order lobster
i didn't order the lobster did you check
in with them and
and see like what happened or was i no
i'm not checking in
like we're not the ones salt on the
wound it is what it is you know like why
was it the best date ever
because it was like that was so okay
well not okay i take it back all right
scratch i scratch that
you know in case he's out there
somewhere and watches it you know we
ain't getting we're hyping him up like
that but
it was it was a cool day there we go
we're taking it back it was a cool date
you're looking for a relationship um
yeah oh like that so were you like this
guy
is like husband material that's why i
was like no
well i mean i think that's too soon
after like a date or two it's too soon
i don't know what you want long term
what the [ __ ] how old are you you're not
married yet that's weird
[Laughter]
we were alone no but i could i bet
dating is [ __ ] hard i don't know i
we ended up just getting together after
the first date but like oh [ __ ]
wait we're walking down though we made
it we're easy for each other we're just
like
yeah since we're both like we're
together we're cereal monogamous
that's why that used to be me and then i
think i don't know it's like this is
like the phase of like singlehood i'm
like oh
that's good like it's you know you're
not enjoying the me time
i mean the me time yes but dating
multiple people i'm not a
like i don't know i just i'm stressful
it is stressful
it is stressful because you're juggling
different guys not like that
i don't know which one to pick they're
all so hot i wish
my way no some decent ones
today's video is brought to you by
raycon wireless earbuds
all right guys check this out there's a
lot of earbuds
on the market right but what changes the
game for me
is how comfortable these bad boys are
like
as you can see i am quite the monk
getting in touch with my zen roots
and sometimes i would like to put into
things into my ear
and get into my meditation mode that's
something new to me that's something
that i want to do
and i like doing it this way because it
blocks out
all the other sound and whatever the
[ __ ] in the world all the mother
bullshits that get into my ears
and most earbuds don't really cancel
noise or like it doesn't really feel
snug it's uncomfortable
but the raycons baby they just go in
like this
and before you know it i am transcending
into another dimension
and it works amazing that's dope recons
are built to perform anywhere and
anytime and they're water resistant as
well as sweat resistant so i don't know
how much you sweat but i'm sure for joe
it's very helpful
because if he's up in the sauna it ain't
gonna fall out and they have up to six
hours of battery time and that's a
pretty long time
for earbuds so if you want something
that lasts long
and won't fall out so if you want to
check out any of the raycon products
go to buy dot com slash off the record
for 15
off all their products just for our
listeners only that's by
raycon dot com slash off the record
hey birthday weekend ray kong why is
dating a nightmare
um just that that people kind of waste
their time and make it seem like they
want more and they really don't
i think people are really looking for a
hookup and it's like if you're looking
for hook up and say that
and then we probably won't waste as much
guys
um i mean different situations sometimes
it could be like a friend of a friend
sometimes out in public social settings
dating apps hell no to the dating apps
i'm so [ __ ] scared of the dating apps
what's so bad about dating apps
because you won't you can't but i'm like
damn none of you you're single i'm like
wait i don't like it i've never even
downloaded the dating app oh you're
worried that somebody's gonna be like
you're so-and-so like i'm not even
popping hot you are
you get me and i think that for me would
be a little embarrassing
and then with the dating apps because
it's like within your area
i'm like what if one of my friends sees
me and they're like hey like
that's not let's not have that
awkwardness because what if all the
dopest dudes are on there they're
knocked out
are you sure i've heard my friends i
know people who have
who have married their fans so you said
married a fan
they married their fans they [ __ ]
their fans and they fell in love and
they married their fans
really yeah that sounds like something i
would do
that's only something a guy would do not
a girl not yet no no
who's oh just old tubers that i've
noticed there's no
old ones that's the old ones see it's
like a dating myth that i'm like
do we really know the person i'm just
saying there's some great fans out there
i think that you should give me a chance
only fans have you have you dated a fan
have you dated a someone that ended up
like turning out the heat yeah my [ __ ]
was creepy as [ __ ] though
because he played it off like oh like
we're we did meet in a public setting so
we
there was no way to plan but he made it
seem like he didn't know me or my work
or anything
and then literally my little after
dating yes then after dating he was like
actually he's like my best friend is the
one that told me who you were and this
and that
no no he's been following yeah
eventually i did my research because
something about that didn't sit right
with me so
then i start like looking on my social
media and i'm like bro you hit me up
years ago and i just like never caught
your message but like
weird as [ __ ] it's just crazy it so you
see what i mean as a woman it's just
hard but what if he changed he's such a
great guy
because he's lying killer vibes i don't
know could have gone into car accident
erased his past memory
you got to give it better than that
plotting [ __ ] is weird but if he was up
front about it and he was
no he totally i'm a [ __ ] mega fan and
then just left it at that even after
like a day or two but the thing that
like he let the relationship kind of
like play out and then
oh you you know me like you could have
just said that like have sex
yeah we dated for a minute okay dad
was it safe of course
then his penis into your vagina i'm just
glad that you weren't the main character
on the first season of you because that
show would be [ __ ] boring
you would have given him the brush off
immediately and then we go we don't have
a show anymore
that's true i'm sorry i'm not that
careless i got you that's a good thing
it's a good thing
it's a competition that changed anything
if he came forward and said i'm a fan
and like would there have been a
relationship or would i mean no we did
have a relationship we did it for
a long time but it was just one of those
where it's kind of like
now i'm kind of i got my eye on you like
what else are you kind of holding back
on
the deception yeah yeah it's like no
dude you found out like six months later
or like two weeks later
i would say maybe like a movie like this
to like a month
oh it's not that much yeah but that is a
long time to put up an app
and i was gonna say and we were kind of
already invested by then like we were
like
dating dating when i was meeting your
people what movie is this
there's a movie just like this where a
guy is like a mega stalker but then he
makes it all
accidental it's all of them i'm like
that's a lot of them
is it a but wasn't something about mary
like this too
or no there's like five stalkers in that
one movies like this yeah there's one
thing about mary's a stalker too
the likable stalker well there's a guy
with the guy with the big teeth the
stalker
his best friend that with all the boys
was a stalker
and then the football player like he's
like he stopped stalking guys yeah i see
everyone we're all like weird friend
zone dudes that like
yeah yeah why can't guys like jason mama
stalk women
did he get it that part
can you imagine
well there's a reason he's not stalking
right because he doesn't need to
women come to him exactly the dating
experience is so different i think for
guys
and girls yes also like how it's done
too but i don't know i think the awesome
part is hooking up for me well maybe
because
before most dudes yeah but but then
you're right about the whole like
um they pretend to date and then like
but all they just want to do is like
[ __ ] bounce
so you have women that are using you for
your sexy body no i don't think so i
think it's all i think guys are
no matter what guys want to [ __ ] right
yeah so they're falling in love with you
in a relationship
or they just want to hook up yeah but
then it's like to me i think the
difference is the patience thing
so like um i don't know when i was
younger i would just [ __ ] everything and
anything
because i'm like that's it it's it's so
it's so precious i need that in my life
right
but then when you have options and it's
like um and then you get older and
you've you've
you're not a virgin anymore it's like uh
yeah i don't really need it that bad
but then when yeah i think it depends on
how desperate they are
that part yeah you know i just
remembered jason momoa
was that guy he was his wife
yeah he he ended up uh saying that when
he was a little boy he saw her on tv he
told his mom mommy i'm going to marry
that guy and he manifested it
yeah though no no no so then
i mean i'm not saying he actually
stopped her he married an old lady
his wife's like 10 10 or 15 years older
than him so he was a little boy what
so he like jailbaited himself
yeah he was much older when they got
together does he know he could get way
younger hotter chicks
i mean he was in love with her though so
then he went after her that's like if i
watch dr quinn medicine woman and i'm
like mommy i'm going to marry her
she's a little bit too old but yes
she was like 60 when we were like 5.
i don't think i've ever seen this before
oh she used to be married she used to be
married to
lenny kravitz she was lenny kravitz's
ex-wife yeah and
zoey kravitz's mom and they look very
very similar she's still she looks like
lenny kravitz
no kind of so kind of she's always zoey
kravitz kind of
no and she's still really hot to this
day she's like so then jason mamo's song
is like mom you're going to marry her
yeah and then he stalked her no i don't
know if he's doctor but he did have a
mutual friend
introduced he's like introduced me to
her i need that exactly so i'm like a
little bit even jason
but what's the difference between a dude
that has
goals and a dude that is a conniving
stalking
dude the deception yeah that's so like
one is like he's out and openly
like she's gonna be my woman yep but i
thought girls also don't even like
the upfrontness no sounds like games you
want a little video
okay let's say you're you're just
chilling at a cafe right yeah mind your
own business writing your your scripts
okay and then baby you want this dick
yeah
a dude walks up and goes wow you're the
most beautiful girl i've ever seen i
want to take you out to a date
most girls are like what that's weird no
not even
it's all in the approach yeah because of
yours like yes oh my god you're the most
beautiful girl
yeah can't be too thirsty ew that can't
be too ugly
deceiving anyone that's upfront yeah but
it's the desperation
too you gotta be chill through the body
creepiness and desperation definitely
about your tone
and the actual script that comes out of
the mouth
what the game is come off as charming
or is it like sometimes what about this
what about a guy comes up and goes oh my
god guess what
i'm a billionaire i'm a billionaire i
got 50 000 bitcoins
then
[Laughter]
why is he got parkinson's issues
like you need help do i need to call
someone for you like okay let's say we
flip the script right like in his script
it's
i'm a billionaire does that like all of
a sudden like
like you know the optometrist number one
or number two and they're like oh [ __ ] i
don't even see the desperation
and i just see the billionaires yeah
that's just that'd be weird if the man's
like approaching you with his money
already like exactly
that's not having gifts hello i am a
billionaire would you like to go to
martha's vineyard with me
oh yeah it's so weird i like it i like
dating
if i was in a serious relationship i
would still like to date okay
so for you because it's like i get to
see a pretty face and flirt and then eat
a nice meal and then i'm like see ya i
like
pretty faces and i like food so it's not
really even sex for you then
i like sex too but then that's already
get that fulfilled
okay but not during quarantine huh
because you're married in this scenario
yeah or like yeah i don't know it's nice
i get to go on the dates with you
oh yeah yeah i would like to date her
too
what all three of you i want to see
her date a hot girl i want to grab my
wife well i'm
sitting on a different table and i have
a newspaper with the eyes cut out and i
can watch them
make out there you go obvious newspaper
so for you is it the chase uh or like if
you
because you were saying how for guys
it's different in the dating world right
because usually you have to go after
girls but you're in a very unique
situation where there's a lot of girls
coming after you
which one do you like better girls
coming after you or are you going after
girls uh
the chase or the whatever i like
connecting so like
if it's reciprocated um i don't really
like
miscommunicating so like if i'm chasing
or if i'm attracted to someone
and then like they're not feeling it or
like we're just not seeing eye to eye
i don't really pursue it that hard
because it feels
weird like for sure but then there's
people that you just communicate really
good with
and i'm like oh [ __ ] yeah because even
with dudes right like when you click
with someone that you can get along with
that energy i like that so i think
that's why i like
dating because it's like oh you found
someone and this one's interesting
but then sometimes people are so
different from you it's funny to just
observe them
dude you i honestly would pay money to
watch you go on dates really
i really would and i would i would not
do the newspaper thing
i would have an ipad with the whole cup
[Laughter]
because you're modern no one has
newspapers yeah you'd stick out like a
sore thumb
but if you have to pick between the two
though if i would if do i like to pursue
yeah are you a chaser or do you like
being chased
uh i think i like to initiate but then
after that
you fall back a little bit i like back
and forth like i like to be
that's the [ __ ] i don't have the energy
for i'm like i don't want to do the cat
and mouse game like i
if we like each other let's just go for
it get married right a little space
no this one no not get married but just
i don't know like if you need a minute
cool boom boom then
you're a girl girls love games you love
bad guys too sounds cool true
i'm dry that's [ __ ] boring i want
regular smegula
you know so then for you in your case
it's like
you had an amazing date yeah what if
this guy is like
well you know i gave her an amazing day
like i connected with her
i would love for her to hit me up for
you it's like no i need to hear from you
first
well my thing is i felt like i was
giving him my energy too and i was
reaching out but even then it just felt
like after the date things were like
fizzling you know down and at that point
i was like if i'm feeling like
all of a sudden you're taking a billion
years to reply or it's taking almost a
[ __ ] day
peace out buddy i'm doing us both a
favor like we're not gonna
that just seems weird to me i just asked
i'd be like man i had really
a lot like that was really fun let's do
it again
and then if they like keep putting it
off i'm like okay
it's probably not the right time you
ever had an awkward like
date cancellation or like flake or
whatever
yeah yeah but i always think like you're
just like whatever
no i just think like they might be going
through something like people are always
going through that's what i thought too
though that's why i see more reason i
was like he might be going through
something
or maybe he's still getting over someone
or whatever so i was like yeah more
reason for me to just
exit out peace out
you